okay so
uh
if he's pushing
right and he's uh we'll just do the one
hand okay so he's pushing on grounding
on that foot you see the ground so if he
lets go i don't go flying you see that
so all right this this foot it's not
relevant everything's on everything's on
this foot push everything's on this one
i'm not leaning into him sophie let's go
then i go flying okay
i just all all this energy is here let's
go and i'm on that foot okay so now
i'm going to uh do my kick
my leg leg kick
everything goes to that foot
everything everything's on this foot
okay
don't keep your wig between your two
legs
okay
but
don't have your foot come back
don't have your weight come back
it's on this foot
this one
this foot
boom comes out
hands don't move don't drop your hands
especially the right leave the right
where it is right where it is boom on
that leg
boom
don't go forward on the kick
okay
try to
so
uh
he's coming at me we'll just have like a
kind of gradual coming at me okay
so i don't want to shift my weight back
move
energy will make me go back okay
so i have to grab my muscle
you see and if you're coming at me then
i don't want to go forward into you okay
so you come at me and boom
here ground
stop
then we'll follow it up with the right
you're going to check that bag that'll
be his lead hand or his rear hand okay
so
kick
check boom
right
make sure your other hand stays up once
you check your other hand comes up
so he's coming in
check boom other hand comes up
okay
now now on the body i'm not i'm not
gonna
kick him so i gotta lighten it up a
little bit now i get some my time
come in
[Music]
hmm
okay that's the same principle that's
going to be the front
french round boom
front round
box
boom front round
so yeah i don't want to just kiss the
bag that's why i need the back foot
[Music]
you're not kissing them
don't drop your hands
stay here
okay let's try it so when you're in a
bag holder you're not all bad
you're holding them back just like when
you're uk you're not a victim there's
aliveness to what you're doing okay or
just like when you do weapons right and
like sancho and you have to receive and
then give receive and give and you're
kenny
uh receiving is not
sitting there taking it swallowing it
that's not what it is okay receiving is
very active there's a lot of agencies a
lot of activeness in it okay so uh
i'm not just standing here like this and
then he goes
okay
oh i'm very alive whenever i can put it
into my stance i put it in my stance he
goes
go ahead dude and i'm gonna measure his
punch do you see see how i measured it
that's one thing i can do
uh if he some of you are making the
mistake of flaring your elbow and he's
coming around my shoulder do you see
that you came from the outside of my
shoulder so if he's going to do that
boom and
i'll bury it with my shoulder
but i'm very active
i'm still looking at my target
do it
okay let's go don't just sit there and
hold the back go so if i'm doing the
first kick i'm not going
i'm not uh just snapping at him there
there's a projection
come in dude come in boom
there's a stopping of his weight he
comes in
boom it stops him okay same thing here
i'm not just
trying to hit that i'm trying to
displace full energy
mass you guys i got to ground this foot
okay and i'm not the one that's
aggressive
the guy's coming in on me it happens a
lot people that tend to do it is boxers
they don't play the leg game do you see
that or people that you keep dancing
around and can't get an angle then he
starts getting all close on you okay so
you're gonna remind him hey hey
okay so the guy's coming in
so i'm not going like this
do you see and i'm not the one going in
we're not doing that
he's coming on me
ground round here
quickly quick
[Music]
not here
through the target
okay let's try it yeah
so again kevin is different from
[Music]
just
getting out of the way okay so that's
why we say receiving receiving okay so
he's trying to scheme me
that's not a candidate that's just
getting out of the way do you understand
oh he goes don't kill me
[Music]
receiving
this
is getting out of the way
okay
so we're doing this
and i'm doing my part
getting out of
in the technique
you see
thank you chad
okay so as as i'm receiving this is
running away
this is countering
receiving
oh i'm right
so same thing
that was from that other skill do you
understand and if i am
running away i was never gonna do it
and if i'm playing technique man
i'm never gonna do it
got it well
what's the difference why do i
go why do i run away
and why do i try to control it before it
matters i'm afraid
i'm afraid so
so here
i don't care if he hits me
so that allows me to be right on the
cusp of it and that's same fear
that same ability to reconcile fear is
what allows me to just deviate
all i needed was one inch of deviation
so same thing here on the punch me
as i go boom
[Music]
but i'm not doing this
i'm staring at my target
it's just a shoulder roll away then i
follow it back in
got it
it's different from this here i go
i go boom
i've just moved the whole base perfectly
out what would happen when he kicked my
leg
it kicks my leg
this is what i get do you see
do you understand
if i move my whole base out perfectly
this is running away from me
and believe me he's coming in and
he's coming in and i oh my that leg he
is not backing out a perfectly solid
base like that okay
all right